What would happen if you were to
bring a tiny pieces, the sun to Earth?
Short answer, you die. Long answer.
It depends which piece of the sun.
Like most of the matter in the universe,
our son is neither solid liquid or gas,
but plasma plasma is when stuff is so
hot that the nuclei and electrons can
separate and flow around freely,
which creates a glue like substance.
So you can imagine our son has an
extremely big spherical ocean of very hot
glue. The deeper you go the dancer
and the wetter the Goo becomes.
So let's bring three samples each the
size of our house to our lab here on earth
and see what happens.
First sample the Chromos fair.
The Chromos fat is the
atmosphere of the sun.
A layer of spouse gas up
to 5,000 kilometers deep.
That's covered in a forest
of plasma spikes. That can
be almost as big as earth.
It's pretty hot here between
6,000 and 20,000 degrees Celsius.
But if we brought a solvent vet to earth,
we're not really getting our money's worth
in the area where we take our sample.
The cruise is fair, is over a
million times less dense than air,
so compared to our
atmosphere at sea level,
it's basically the same as bringing
the vacuum of space down to earth.
The moment our sample arrives,
it would immediately be crushed by
Earth's atmospheric pressure and implode.
Our would rush to fill the vacuum and
use as much energy as 12 kilograms of TNT
in the process.
This creates a high pressure shockwave,
which shatters glass, ruptures, air
drums, and maybe some internal organs.
If you're standing too close,
it could kill you,
so you'd better keep your testers.
Let's go deeper.
The second sample,
the photosphere beneath the Chromos
fair is the glowing surface of the sun,
the fitters fair,
which produces the light.
We see it's covered in a grade of
a million hotspots called granules,
each of them about as big as the United
States and over 5,000 degrees Celsius.
These granules, other tops of
convective columns, churning gas,
that brings the heat up from the
center of the sun to its surface.
In these columns, a few hundred kilometers
down, we take our second plasma sample.
It has about the same pressure
as our atmosphere on earth,
though still much less dense than air.
It's heat support says
so it won't implode.
Our sphere now carries
twice as much energy,
as much as 25 kilograms of TNT that this
time has heat for a dazzling instant.
This plasma would glow
with a million times.
The brightness of the sun seemed from
earth instantly lighting fires throughout
our lab, but a few milliseconds later,
those fires are all that's left.
The plasma has cooled to harness gas
floating up from the flaming Roy's.
What if we go deeper?
Third sample,
the radius of zone here,
the plasma is about 2 million degrees
Celsius and so dense and tightly packed.
The creates a sort of maze for itself.
Energy in the form of
photons tries to escape,
but it has to wonder for hundreds of
thousands of years bouncing endlessly from
particle to particle until it
eventually finds an access.
Bringing matter from here to our lab
is what experts call a very bad idea.
As soon as it arrives in our lab,
the extreme pressure that holds the
plasma tightly together is gone and the
material explodes with the
power of a thermonuclear weapon.
Our lab was what does the city around
it will be destroyed in an instant.
On the bright side,
there won't be any radioactive
fallout with our lamp destroyed.
We can abandon the illusion that
we're trying to do any science today.
What if we go much, much
deeper? Last sample,
the core hair in the
central 1% of the staff,
we find a third of the sun's mass.
The matter here is compressed by the
weight of the entire star above it.
In the center of the core,
the temperature is 15 million degrees,
has enough to make helium by smashing
together hydrogen powering the sun by
nuclear fusion in billions of
years after the death of the son.
This call will remain as a wide off.
If we brought a sample of it to earth,
it would cause a lot of inconvenience.
The biggest nuclear weapon ever designated
had an energy of 40 megatons of TNT
or acute the size of the
empire state building.
Our sample has the equivalent
of 4,000 Vaca towns.
This is 4 billion tons of TNT or a cube,
1.3 kilometers high.
To give you a sense of scale,
this is the cube inside Manhattan.
Once the sphere arrives on earth,
this super dense matter expands instantly
and creates an explosion with the
force of,
well the sun.
If we get the sample in
Paris in the morning,
the citizens of London would see
what looks like a second sunrise,
but one that gets brighter and brighter
and hotter and hotter until London burns
to ashes in a radius of about
300 kilometers around the blast,
everything would be birthed.
The shock wave would travel
around the earth multiple times.
Most buildings in central
Europe would be flattened.
Eardrums would rupture and windows
break across the continent.
The explosion would be apocalyptic,
possibly human civilization ending.
If humans did survive,
we could count on the dust blown into
the atmosphere to create a small ice age.
So if there is one tiny bright side,
it would be that the explosion might be
an effective way to control human caused
climate change for a few decades.
While this is definitely a good thing.
All in all we conclude that we should
not try to bring the sun to Earth.
We've made a lot of questionable
assumptions, this video,
but our maths is real.
If you're like us and you enjoy using the
power of math to calculate absurd ways
to destroy stuff,
he may be interested in all the other
things you can do with maths. For example,
you could calculate how to mind mercury
for silicon to build a Dyson sphere.
Determine how long it will take the
sun to burnout or simply do your taxes.
But as much as we love
explaining these things,
the best way to learn anything
is by doing it yourself.
Brilliant is a problem solving website
that teaches you to think like a
scientist by guiding you through problems.
They take concepts like these and
break them up into bite sized nuggets,
present clear thinking in each part and
then build back up to an interesting
conclusion.
If you visit brilliant.org/nutshell all,
click the link in the description.
You can sign up for free and
learn all kinds of things.
And as a bonus for courts, cause
I'd viewers, the first 200 people,
we'll also get 20% off
that annual membership.